so the the u.s. women's team won the
World Cup this we do what you switch is
great news
job well done it's a nice accomplishment
if only soccer was not a communist
conspiracy I think I could celebrate it
even more I mean it's it's a fine little
game okay don't don't get me wrong I
don't it's just that I prefer sports and
I love America that's the only so that's
those are the two things that prevent me
from really appreciating and enjoying
and more is just the fact that I'm a
patriot and also a sports fan but if I
wasn't any of those then I think I would
I would like it more in it I'm not
criticizing soccer
just because I'm calling it a fake sport
loved by commies and traitors doesn't
mean they don't crit sound of criticism
it's just a it's just it's an
observation so don't I don't you take it
the wrong way if you're sports fan but
you know we're told that the success of
the women's team means that they should
finally have equal pay right that they
should finally be paid equal to the man
the men that they're paid a lot less
than a men's soccer players supposedly
and this is a sexist conspiracy is what
we are being told I want to deal with
that claim today to start with because
there's just it's it's this whole thing
about equal pay in sports of all places
it's just so in blue Matic I think of
where we are as a society because the
whole conversation is so cartoonishly
stupid and off base so we're going to
talk about that but first I want to tell
you a little bit about freedom project
Academy I've talked about that before
and there's a reason because you know
that this year nearly seventy billion
dollars of taxpayer money will be spent
on public education that's seventy
billion with a B yet there's a new
report that came out that finds that
just two and five American students are
actually ready to attend college when
they come out and most of those students
are coming out of public school so many
of you have obviously been searching for
an alternative something different a
school with traditional values that help
students develop strong foundations in
math and science English American
history you know in education that
actually is focused on
education and not on making your kid
into a woke sjw and importantly an
education that teaches kids how to think
rather than just giving them what to
think giving them things to regurgitate
onto a piece of paper and that is where
freedom project Academy comes in it's an
accredited online school built on
judeo-christian values and classical
curriculum for students from
kindergarten all the way through high
school we're talking about a complete
interactive educational experience where
students attend live classes with other
students from across the country Freedom
Project Academy provides live and
recorded lessons homework tests tutoring
grades transcripts so if you want to
learn more about this if you want to get
enrolled which I would suggest doing and
you got to do it soon because the
enrollment ends on July 19th so don't
wait too long you got a couple more
weeks go to freedom for school.com
freedom for school comm and request your
free information packet don't forget to
subscribe to their weekly education
podcast the dr. Duke show available on
iTunes and everywhere else where you can
get podcasts again enrollment ends July
19th so take back control of your kids
education freedom for school comm
freedom for school comm freedom for
school dot-com okay now equal pay for
soccer players I think that if people
were better educated maybe they'd have a
better understanding of these kinds of
conversations some presidential
candidates have have also called for
this Camilla Harris I think kirsten
gillibrand or Bernie Sanders they're all
the same I don't know the women's
players have made the same point saying
that they should get equal pay and then
the crowd there at the stadium in France
after the the victory during the
celebration they started chanting equal
pay equal pay so I want to just for a
few moments focus on this issue which as
I said is is theirs it just shows you
where we are and I think it
reveals why our conversations about
controversial issues oftentimes don't go
anywhere because things like facts and
logic just aren't allowed to enter into
the discussion so first of all I keep
hearing this claim that and this is one
of the things that the Equal Pay
discussion is based on this claim that
the women's team is better than the
men's team because the men's team
doesn't win anything and the women's
team keeps winning the World Cup and all
joking aside I do respect their success
I think it's I mean they're good at what
they do and I respect anybody who's good
at what they do as long as what they do
is morally appropriate and I think
arguably soccer is morally appropriate
though there's a discussion to be had
there we won't get into it
the men's team I guess is not very good
in comparison to other men's teams
across the globe because that's how we
have we're judging this if you say oh
the the women's team is better than the
men's team you must mean by that when
you say it that the men's team is not as
good compared to their competition as
the women's team is against their
competition and one of the reasons for
that is in this country I think the best
male athletes end up going into
different sports I mean oh I should say
they end up going into sports like
soccer I mean sorry football I apologize
for that slip it was offensive they end
up going into sports like football
basketball baseball and that's where I
think the best athletes go whereas in
other countries the best male athletes
almost all play soccer so they're in
other countries they are Kevin Durant's
and their Odell Beckham's
go to soccer where ours go to basketball
baseball football but even so there's no
question at all that the men's team is
better pound-for-pound than the women's
team they may not be better against
their competition but when you say the
women's team is better if you actually
mean that you think the women's team
would beat the men's team like they
actually are better athletes period
they're just better at playing soccer
well then you must
be drunk or high because or
brain-damaged there's just no way you
could actually think that now if you
were to put if the men's team as bad as
they are against the against other men
if you were to put them on the women's
circuit they would win every game 50 to
nothing including beating the women
handily and one of the ways we know that
is that number one they're men and so
they're just they're male they may not
be the best athletes that the best male
athletes that America has to offer but
even so they are relatively successful
male athletes in soccer which means that
they're just gonna be better than the
women and it's as simple as that as I
pointed out before the women's team a
couple years ago lost to a bunch of
14-year old boys and the only and look
it's not this is not mockery the only
reason I bring that up is because there
are people out there claiming and they
do appear to actually think that the
women's team is literally better than
the men's team and when you hear that
claim then you have to say okay yeah but
they lost too they lost the 14 year old
boys and you could say all you want was
a scrimmage they weren't trying that
hard okay you know I mean do you think
this men's team wins there's any chance
they would lose to 14 year old girls
they could be out there on what they can
be hopping around on one leg and they
would still beat fourteen-year-old girls
so and that just shows you all it does
it just shows you the biological
difference between men and women that's
all that is and so it's you know when we
say that men are better at a sport than
women that's not like all that means
that men just have a biological
advantage they didn't really do anything
to earn that inherent biological
advantage if they become great athletes
and they've done a lot to earn that but
just the very fact that they are men
provides them with advantages this is
one of the reasons why myself and every
other same person were all against the
idea of putting biological men into
women's sports biological men who claim
to be women were against putting them
into women's sports just because of that
incredible biological advantage they
have it's just not fair now the other
side of this is the matter of of revenue
as for that let me read from Forbes an
article written by Mike Ozan Ian
a few months ago here's what he says he
says I read from his he says as Dwight
Jaynes pointed out four years ago after
the u.s. women beat Japan to capture the
World Cup in Vancouver there's a big
difference in the revenue available to
pay the team's the Women's World Cup
brought in almost seventy three million
dollars of which the players got 13% the
2020 the 2010 Men's World Cup in South
Africa made almost four billion dollars
of which nine percent went to the
players the men still pull the world the
World Cup money wagon the Men's World
Cup in Russia generated over six billion
dollars in revenue with the
participating teams sharing four hundred
million dollars less than seven percent
of revenue meanwhile the Women's World
Cup is expected to earn 131 million for
the four-year cycle 29 to 20 2019 to
2022 and dole out 30 million dollars to
the participating teams okay that's what
that's what Forbes says so let's think
about these numbers for a minute
the men will share 400 million dollars
from the six billion they brought in the
women will share 30 million from the 131
million they brought in so that's what
for the women that's what 20 percent or
something like that 20-some percent 20
percent verse 7 percent by that figure
it's not the if women want to be paid
equally then they should be paid less
women are actually overpaid equal pay
should mean that they that they they get
an equal share in the revenue they
generate which means they should get 7
or 8 percent or I should say they should
get yea if they if they so it 131
million the women the men got six seven
percent so equal pay would mean the
women would get six or seven percent
which means that they would share I
don't know eight or nine million bucks
not thirty million
but if they want equal pay in terms of
just the pure amount they get to share
which would mean they also get to share
four hundred million dollars then that
would mean that they are paid almost
four times the amount that they generate
in revenue so where is that extra money
even coming from the entire you know
Women's World Cup it only generates a
hundred thirty one million if they want
equal pay they want 400 million dot wet
where's the extra almost three hundred
million dollars coming from it's just
that it's a claim that does that's why I
call it a a cartoonishly stupid
discussion it has no basis in reality
the the men in women in terms of revenue
and also skill are in two different
universes and that explains why women
are paid less in sports it's it's the
same thing in basketball and we hear
this sometimes this complaint that WNBA
players are paid much much much much
much less than NBA players which is true
now I don't have the I don't have the
averages in front of me the average
amount that an NBA player is paid versus
a WNBA player but I'm sure that the
differences are are huge but that's
because the difference in revenue is
huge the whole league okay WNBA the
whole league generates sixty million
dollars in a year the whole league
WNBA the NBA with men generates eight
billion okay the NBA generates
significantly more in a week than the
WNBA generates in a year so that's why
the men get paid more there's more money
to share there's just more money to go
around
I mean if men if we were to get you give
equal pay in the WNBA well giving them
the women an equal amount to the men by
raising their salary would just be
impossible because the money doesn't
exist it's just not there to give them
so the only way to really give them
equal pay would be to give the men a lot
lot less but then the question is who
gets all the extra money
just goes to the owners or excuse me
we're not supposed to call them owners
now they're their governors because
owner is racially insensitive so the
rest goes to the governor's it sounds so
stupid so I can't even say even if I
wanted to be politically correct I can't
say it I can't refer to NBA team owners
as NBA governors it's just so creepy and
weird so that's the thing the money is
there because there's so much interest
in the NBA and that's why the men get
paid more
there is almost no interest in the WNBA
that's why the money isn't there and the
reason why there's no interest is
because if just not that fun to watch I
mean these are you're watching
basketball with players who can't even
dunk and again that's not an insult it's
just a fact it's one of the one of the
exciting things about watching
basketball is to watch the or the
high-flying acrobatics the dunks and all
that crazy stuff well the women can even
do that
so many of them anyway so it's just not
as fun to watch how do you account for
that gap the the gap in interest the
fact that there are more people
interested in men's sports than are
interested in women's sports is it
patriarchy is it because of the
internalized misogyny of sports fans
that we all prefer to watch men play
sports
well no men are just better at sports
and therefore they're more exciting to
watch faster stronger they jump higher
they dribble faster they're quicker
everything is more exciting same for
soccer now while I hesitate to call
soccer exciting in any context
it certainly is more exciting when men
play it then when women play it because
they're just better at it and that's all
there is to it
now so that I'm not accused of being a
sec well too late for that I will be
accused of being a sexist
which which is you know just another
another day in the neighborhood for me
but let's let's look at a different
comparison and one that works out in in
favor of women okay let's look at a
different industry the modeling industry
I had to look this up because I don't
know what I've thought my head but
apparently from what I read
top 10 highest paid male models in the
country made eight million dollars
collectively last year those are the top
10 highest paid so that's less than a
million bucks apiece
meanwhile the single highest paid female
model made three times that amount just
by herself okay the top 10 female models
made collectively ten times what the
what the what the men what the top ten
men made is that a sexist conspiracy in
the other direction
is there some kind of gender pay gap in
the other direction or now we have two
equal things out so that male models
make the same as female models no female
models earn more because they're worth
more and why are they worth more well
for one thing women are more beautiful
than men okay it's a little bit harder
to quantify Beautif beautiful there's no
question that women generally are more
beautiful than men if you think of all
the people you've ever seen in your life
or met who just had just had stunning
earth-shattering Beauty right probably
all of them are women if you go out in
public or if you're watching TV or
whatever and you're just and and you see
someone's just so incredibly beautiful
then most of the time that's gonna be a
woman and the thing is even if you're a
woman yourself that's probably true in
your experience where you yourself if
you're out in public and you happen to
notice that somebody is extremely
beautiful probably that somebody who
you're noticing is a woman and because
it's just sort of we say beauty is in
the eye of the beholder well it's really
not a beautiful woman is just a
beautiful woman it's just it's just a
it's a fact that you recognize nothing
more nothing more to it than that not
only that so that's
one thing that women have in the
modeling industry it's an advantage that
they have that they're just more
beautiful the you know I don't know who
the top ten female models are but I
imagine that if you saw them this is a
way what those are beautiful women it's
extremely beautiful that's why they make
all that money also there's more for a
female model to do she can model clothes
she could model jewelry she can model
makeup male models can model clothes
mostly but men don't buy nearly as much
jewelry and thank God they don't buy
nearly as much makeup although I think
the left wants to change that disparity
but as it stands right now most men
don't buy makeup so if you're looking
for if you're a jewelry company or a
makeup company and you're looking for a
model to show off your product 90 times
99 times out of a hundred you're gonna
pick a female model and that's why
female models make more and that's all
that's it they're just they're worth
more for those reasons they have
biological advantages and they have they
have which translate into advantages in
the marketplace there you go now going
back to the soccer thing for a minute we
have to realize that there's two
conversations here because there's
there's the amount that the women get
paid by FIFA which is the international
soccer organization the organization
that that gives out the the World Cup
money and that's where that big gap is
the 30 million versus 400 million and
that's where the big revenue gap is the
six billion verse 131 million and then
there's also a discussion of what's what
US soccer players are paid here by US
soccer and that's where the revenue gap
is is isn't actually it's I think from
what I read just when you look at US
soccer alone historically men generate
more revenue but that gap has been
closing in recent years so okay fine but
then if you look at what US soccer pays
their athletes the the pay gap is also
not very large like if you look at the
top five highest-paid male soccer
players versus female yeah the men are
paid a little bit more but it's not it's
not an enormous gap
the big gap is with FIFA it's with the
World Cup money okay and we should be
clear that when when people talk about
the pay gap and they want to they want
to close the gender pay gap ins in
soccer they are referring to FIFA also
Megan Rapinoe she's been in front of
cameras specifically calling out FIFA
for the pay gap the FIFA president
apparently was was booed at the World
Cup largely over this issue even though
the men in the World Cup generate forty
to fifty to sixty times the amount in
revenue and so that's how absurd this
discussion is all right um speaking of
absurd speaking of absurd discussions
and fake controversies I wanted to
mention this so Disney is a company that
has well ran out of original ideas
probably 25 years ago and so they just
announced that there's another
live-action remake of a popular cartoon
in the works actually there's a few so
they're doing a Mulan remake apparently
live-action and and now they're also
doing a Little Mermaid a live-action
thing I mean just think about think
about how bereft of creativity the
creative trust at Disney is where now
they're reduced to staging these literal
shot-for-shot reenactments of their own
films from only a few years these are
films from the 90s sometimes the late
night me when did Mulan come out the
late 90s wasn't even that long ago and
now they're doing a shot-for-shot ring
enactment uh but it's not even like
they're they're giving us a new
interpretation of the original material
you know it's it's not even it's just
they're taking the the cartoon and just
redoing it almost all the same dialogue
everything redoing it with real people
we've got this Lion King thing coming
out and they call it a live-action Lion
King well it's not live-action because
all the characters are animals so this
is really just this is this is a this is
an animated remake of an animated film
the only difference is that the
animation is more realistic but who
cares if the animation is realistic
these are talking animals it's not a
realistic situation in fact I think if
you if you if you have a it just it
looks somehow even more ridiculous to
have a realistic animal talking if
you're gonna have talking animals just
make it a cartoon because that's what it
is
but even in that they're they're hiring
some of the same voice actors so they're
getting they're getting a non-black
Knaus name anyway they're getting the
same how am i blank now is in there
they're getting the same actor for who
voiced Mufasa a very famous tiger -
they're getting him from the nine to two
voice Mufasa again so in this case it's
going to be a shot-for-shot remake with
even some of the same voice actors and
it's just what's the point of this well
the point is it's a it's a soulless cash
grab and they're doing it because they
don't have any original ideas anyway so
the Little Mermaid a little mermaid is
coming out and they announced last week
that the Ariel the the person who's
going to play Ariel is an R&B singer
named Halle Bailey
Halle Bailey and she's going to take on
this challenging role of a mermaid and
she's a black woman okay and the news of
this casting arrangement was was greeted
mostly with mild shrugs from the vast
majority of grownups who really are too
busy paying bills and taking care of
their kids to worry about which actress
is portraying a fictional fish woman in
the next Disney film but in some
quarters of society it the news prompted
exuberant celebration as it finally am
you know explodes the pernicious and
harmful myth that all aquatic creatures
are Caucasian because this is apparently
something that people thought I guess
and now we're learning that's not the
case so little girls of all races can
now dream of one day living in a coral
reef and doing battle with an evil
octopus who communicates her dastardly
plans by singing
spontaneous musical numbers now I guess
any girl of any race can dream about
that most people don't care about any of
this
right I mean it's a Disney film that can
have whoever they want who cares but
that's not the story if you were if you
were paying attention to the to the news
and you were on line last week
especially late last week that's not the
story that was being told in fact if you
were to go right now and Google Arial or
The Little Mermaid you're gonna be
greeted with dozens of articles
reporting on an alleged outrage among
racists who were supposedly very angry
that their favorite cartoon mermaid has
changed colors apparently there was this
huge outrage all these races like oh no
we can't have a black woman playing a
mermaid oh I'm racist and I don't want
that that's what people supposedly were
saying according to the media in fact
there was a hashtag trending on Twitter
a hashtag not my Ariel was trending on
Twitter with a hundred thousand people
or over a hundred thousand people
tweeting about it on whatever it was
Wednesday or Thursday the problem though
is that easily 95% of the tweets in the
hashtag not my Ariel hashtag were we're
from were not from people outraged about
the casting but we're from people
outraged at the people who were outraged
about the casting so you go now you can
look through it yourself and you'll be
hard-pressed to find a single person who
appears to be authentically angry that
Ariel is not white almost everybody is
angry that people are allegedly angry
that Ariel isn't white and this is one
of the things that Twitter specializes
in it specializes in people being
outraged about an outrage that doesn't
appear to actually exist BT put an
article out on their website declaring
in their headline racists are big mad
that a black girl is playing Ariel in
the Little Mermaid that was the headline
now leaving aside the phrase big mad
which is very annoyingly stupid to prove
that these quote big mad racists do in
fact exist
et provides precisely six tweets two of
those tweets are from anonymous accounts
with less than 10 followers it don't
appear to be real people two are from
non-white people who for whatever reason
thought that erielle should still be
white and then there was another tweet
from and this is actually one that the
website complex the website the Daily
Dot a few other websites they did entire
articles about this one supposedly
racist tweet from a now suspended
account and it appears that that account
which I think sort of started all this
is a sock puppet with a stolen profile
photo which is probably why it's
suspended in other words a sock puppet
account is a it's a fake account so
somebody using a fake account with a
stolen profile photo of a sort of
generic looking blonde chick but white
blonde chick someone using that account
started this pretended to be outraged
about the fact that Ariel's not white
and started this whole thing now I have
noticed a few real people annoyed not
that that Ariel is black but just
annoyed by the double standard because a
white cartoon character could be
portrayed by a black accurate actress
but of course a black character could
never be portrayed by a white actress so
that's the double standard in fact the
they came out with the remake of Aladdin
which apparently was horrible and I
remember that there was some grief that
that movie caught because the woman
playing jasmine was not Arab enough like
she was she was Arab but not Arab enough
she was a little bit too white looking
and so that created some outrage
you know you now you now find people
upset when gay characters and films are
portrayed by straight actors so when
there's when there's a switch in that
direction it does create actual
legitimate outrage mostly from liberals
and they've got this Mulan remake coming
out can you imagine if a non Asian woman
was cast
in you know as that is in the
protagonist role of the Mulan movie can
you imagine if they had like I don't
know Amy Adams or something playing no
it could never happen or the what's a
princess and the Frog
Tiana which is that the you know a black
princess can you imagine when that when
they do that remake which they will can
you imagine what would happen if they
had a white actress playing Tiana that
again would be legitimate real outrage
from the left so I have seen a few
people pointing this out and saying hey
look you know I don't really care who
plays Ariel but the fact is you're
switching her race you're telling me I
can't be upset about that I'm not but
the fact is if we were to switch it in
the other direction with a different
movie you would really be upset about it
so that's a double standard that's
hypocrisy so I have people point out but
that's that's not out again that's not
outraged over the casting that is just
annoyance over hypocrisy and double
standards which is totally justified now
personally you know I think people of
any race should be able to play
fictional characters of any race I don't
think it matters it's all imaginary so
make James Bond black doesn't matter you
can make shaft white who cares make them
both Chinese make them green with purple
stripes I mean what does it matter they
don't exist it's fiction the Little
Mermaid is also fiction but so is the
outrage surrounding it this is yet
another phony backlash invented by
people who are ideologically invested in
the idea that America is so racist that
we can't even have black mermaids
without the racist Nazis getting upset
about it so this is an invented outrage
it's like the Starbucks cup thing you
remember a few years ago we were told by
the media that conservative Christians
were outraged and and we're very upset
that the Starbucks cups were not
Christmassy enough and then when you
looked into it as I did you found that
there were maybe like two or three
actual conservative Christians who are
really for some reason dumb enough to be
upset that there weren't enough
snowflakes on the on the on the holiday
cups at Starbucks everybody else didn't
care this was mostly a controversy and
out
invented by the media to push a
narrative and to make conservatives and
Christians look stupid and they do it
all the time
and they did it again with this Little
Mermaid thing and that's another reason
why you have to be very careful when
you're consuming news or when you hear
about some outrage all your parent lis
everyone's outraged about this or that
well you should always stop and ask are
they really outraged about this go look
into it yourself and many times you'll
discover that now actually nobody cares
let's see one other one other thing
there was maybe we'll say this for
tomorrow there was this incident at a
Starbucks in Arizona where some police
officers say they were asked to leave
the store or move to a different
location
because their presence was upsetting to
some other customers who felt unsafe
around police officers and I think that
this this is something that needs a lot
longer covers I think we'll save this
for tomorrow but the thing I want to
talk about tomorrow with this issue is
the comparison that's being drawn
between this and the time that you may
remember a couple years ago where there
were some black customers or they
weren't customers that's the point but
some black men at a Starbucks in Philly
who were asked to leave refused to leave
then the cops were called on them and
Starbucks in that case I'm not going to
defend them when it comes to them asking
the police officers to leave and of
course I'll be accused all it's because
you're racist you know because those are
black men's of course well no there's a
key difference between those two
situations and we'll talk about that
tomorrow let's get two emails actually
Matt Walsh Oh at gmail.com
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com his email
address this is from
Phil says Matt I see you've had several
successes fishing police tell us if your
son was president how he reacted well I
had to just read this email because I
was bragging on Twitter about the fact
that I did catch a five pound and then a
six pound bass last week we were staying
at a lake you know at an undisclosed
location and I won't disclose disclose
it because I don't want anyone else
taking my bass from that location and
anyway yeah my son did do a fair amount
of fishing with me and they were very
excited by by those successes five and
six pound bass you know no big deal
actually there's kind of a big deal so
you should I just wanted you to know
that this is from Lisa says greetings
Matt a common point people will raise
when refuting refuting the idea of
universal health care is that nobody has
a right to another person's labor in
this case the doctors I agree with this
point of course but I was watching a
crime documentary recently and heard the
words right to an attorney
I was then reminded that everyone has
the right to an attorney even if they
can't afford one the government will pay
for one in that case the words right to
an attorney are not contested at all in
this country this isn't a controversy
anywhere isn't this the same concept how
can we say that nobody has a right to a
doctor's labor if everyone has the right
to an attorney's labor I haven't been
able to figure this one out that's uh
that's a really interesting point that I
hadn't thought of before so I had to
think about this for a minute when I got
your email Lisa yesterday and so I think
that this is the way to sort through it
the right to an attorney we should be
clear doesn't cover all types of
attorneys there are many different types
of attorneys that are in different
avenues of law and deal with different
things so for instance if you're suing
Walmart because you slipped on a banana
peel at the in the produce section you
don't have a right to an attorney to
represent you for that case and if you
get sued by someone because they're
walking through your kitchen and they
slip on a banana peel then you don't
have a right to an attorney to defend
you use it you're on your own you got to
do that on your own
the right to an attorney applies only to
a defense when you're being prosecuted
by the state so that's when you have the
right to an attorney
and in that case the attorney that is
compelled to help you as a public
defender someone who chooses to work for
an agency whose role it is to provide
defense for people who can't afford to
pay so it's not even set you know there
are there are private there are defense
attorneys who are in private practice
and it cost a lot of money and they're
the ones who can you know help you get
away literally get away with murder but
you don't have a right to them because
yeah that would be essentially slave
labor the government can't come in to
some you know high profile private
expensive defense attorney and say oh
you have to help this guy that's
specifically public defenders and if you
choose to get into the role a big a
public defender well this is what you do
I think the the key difference though
and the reason for that is that if if
the state brings a case against you then
the way our laws work and I think it's a
good this is good the state brings a
case against you the state should also
have to provide you the means to defend
yourself in that case so that's why
that's why you have the right to an
attorney
because the state they're the ones
coming in and saying hey you know we're
gonna put you on trial we're gonna try
to lock you in prison and and if if we
didn't have that right to an attorney
then the fear is that there would be
major abuses and the state could just
with impunity just lock people away and
they'd have no chance of defending
themselves so that's that's the point
I've often said and I'm not the only one
who's made this point but I think
sometimes we we are focusing on the
wrong R word we talk a lot about rights
I have the right to this I have the
right to that I think maybe we should be
talking more about responsibility I
think we should think of rights in terms
of responsibility and when we think of
it in those terms it starts to clarify
issues to a large extent because every
right has a corresponding responsibility
and we don't talk enough about that so
another way of looking at this is okay
you have a right to an attorney
well that's true but it's more that the
state has a responsibility to provide
you with the means to defend yourself if
they're the ones who are trying to put
you in prison so you have a right to it
but you have a right to it because of
the responsibility that's on the state
that's how we should look at it I've
said the same
we talk about the right-to-life with the
with with abortion and it well it's true
that we do have a right to life but I
think maybe a sort of clearer way of
looking at this is that as a parent you
have a responsibility to your children
and that's what this comes down to
that's your child you have a
responsibility to them and and so you
you can't kill them you have to take
care of them or you have to find someone
who can take care of them so that's how
I would look at that and that's that's
an interesting question though thanks
for bringing up bringing up an angle
that I hadn't thought of before I think
we'll leave it there thanks everybody
for watching thanks for listening
Godspeed
the u.s. women's national soccer team
which two years ago was beaten five to
two by a team of boys under the age of
15 has won the World Cup or something we
will analyze with the rise of soccer
means for American politics then
President Trump parades tanks through DC
a 2020 Democrat may drop out of the race
and Nancy Pelosi snipes at AOC check it
out on the Michael Noel's show